over the weekend a hearthstone player
made international headlines for
protesting the Chinese government during
a tournament stream Blizzard immediately
pulled the footage but since then they
banned the player taking away his prize
money and fire the casters were on the
stream with him this is an extremely
messy and complicated story so let's
just get right into it
[Music]
all right I promise I'm gonna get to par
stone and Blizzard and eSports in just a
minute but first I have to explain
what's going on between China and Hong
Kong right now Hong Kong isn't like
every other part of China it's what's
called a special administrative region
which means it has its own laws its own
government and perhaps most importantly
no extradition treaty with the rest of
China what that means is that if a
person who resides in Hong Kong commits
a crime in China or against China they
can't be sent to China for punishment
once they're back in Hong Kong that's a
pretty bare-bones explanation of
extradition treaties but I think it's
all we're gonna need for our purposes
right now anyway a few months ago Hong
Kong's government started considering a
new extradition bill one that would
allow the chief executive that's the
head of state of Hong Kong to extradite
anyone who is in Hong Kong to anywhere
that Hong Kong didn't have an
extradition treaty with including China
that scared a lot of people partially
because they were concerned that people
who were critical of China's ruling
Communist Party would be extradited and
punished something that happens in China
all the time that fear led to a demand
for a more independent democratic
government for Hong Kong and that demand
was the protests
it was the most unified protest not in
the city in more than a decade
some two million protesters took to the
streets on June 16th
calling mrs. Carey Lam to the to draw
the bill all right now let's get to the
esports parts of this video during a
hearthstone grandmasters asia-pacific
broadcast on the official Taiwanese
hearthstone channel a player from Hong
Kong named blitz Chun won a
regular-season match and in a postgame
interview
showed up in a gas mask took it off and
announced something along the lines of
liberate Hong Kong revolution of our age
now as soon as that happened the two
casters were on stream stuck their heads
under their monitors presumably because
they didn't want to be associated with
what was about to happen and then the
producer immediately cut to an ad break
by the time everybody in the rest of the
world woke up and found out what
happened Blizzard had already removed
the bog from twitch but a few days ago
Blizzard took things a step too far
for most people Blizzard has banned
blitz chunk the player who made the
statement for a year he's obviously been
removed from the rest of the
grandmasters season and any prize money
he would have received has been reduced
to zero the two casters were on stream
were also fired
they say that Blizzard violated one of
the grandmasters tournament rules
specifically rules 6.10 which goes
something like this
engaging in any act that in Blizzard
sole discretion brings you into public
disrepute offends a portion or group of
the public or otherwise damages
blizzards image will result in removal
from grandmasters and reduction of the
players prize total to zero US dollars
in addition to other remedies which may
be provided for under the handbook and
blizzards website terms so to put that
into English Blizzard has decided that
which tongue statements offended a
portion of the public specifically the
portion that isn't a big fan of the Hong
Kong protests Blizzard also had this to
say in their statement we'd like to
re-emphasize tournament and player
conduct within the hearthstone eSports
community from both players and talents
while we stand by one's right to express
individual thoughts and opinions players
and other participants that elect to
participate in our eSports competitions
must abide by the officials comp
rules which basically means that you're
allowed to have political opinions
Blizzard would just prefer that you
don't state them on stream if they're
gonna offend anyone specifically if
they're gonna offend the Chinese
government now look this kind of
language isn't a lot of contracts and
rule books blizzard needs it to deal
with people who say racist stuff on
stream or make death threats the issue
is the way that Blizzard is choosing to
enforce that rule in this particular
circumstance their statement says that
they stand by people expressing
political opinions and well that's
exactly what blitz Chung did but he got
banned why well we're gonna get into
that in a second but first let's talk
about the reaction from the hearthstone
community when the announcement happens
the front page of the hearthstone
subreddit was basically entirely just
people saying they wanted refunds or
were quitting the game because of
blizzards decision the blizzards
subreddit was also walked by moderators
shortly after the announcement
presumably because of a controversy as
well meanwhile even people within
Blizzard are pretty upset the overwatch
community is trying to turn me into a
mascot for the Hong Kong protests and
even collegiate hearthstone players are
firing back calling for a boycott of
Blizzard scape over this is Spence won't
last any longer they do draw the second
divine spirit as for the wider eSports
community well it's all anyone can talk
about this has become an enormous
international story it's made headlines
all over the world it's pretty much the
biggest story in gaming right now
because well people think that Blizzard
messed up and some are speculating why
this may have happened and a lot of them
are pointing fingers to blizzards ties
to Chinese companies $0.10 a massive
Chinese gaming company has a 5%
ownership share in Blizzard and on top
of that
Blizz does pretty big business in China
there are four Chinese overwatch League
teams one of which is owned by net eat
one of the largest gaming and Internet
companies in the world who just so
happened to release all of blizzards
games in China clearly Blizzard games
and IP are popular in China and one
might speculate that the company has a
lot to lose if their Chinese business
partners aren't happy with them and
listen this isn't just Blizzard most of
these massive gaming companies have some
ties to China Riot Games is partially
owned by $0.10 and there are allegations
that right now at the League of Legends
World Championship casters aren't
allowed to
all a specific team by their real name
Hong Kong attitude is mostly being
referred to on broadcast as hka as if we
don't all know what that means
and people are speculating that that's
because a riot doesn't want people
saying Hong Kong on a broadcast
that's absurd but that's how deep this
stuff can go a very similar controversy
happened recently in the NBA of all
places the general manager of the
Houston rocket tweeted support for the
Hong Kong protests and though he deleted
it and apologized it still led to a lot
of Chinese businesses including ten cent
hand the Chinese consulate in Houston
pulling support from the Rockets and the
NBA at large in some cases the state-run
TV network that airs NBA games in China
announced that they were no longer gonna
broadcast the preseason games that were
being played in China on top of that
they said that they were gonna take a
second look at any future business deals
with the NBA it's not that dissimilar of
a story but the big difference is that
the Commissioner of the NBA stated his
support for people expressing their
political opinions
well Blizzard cracked down on it so
hopefully now you understand why people
on the internet can't stop talking about
this story it's basically just another
part of a massive geopolitical story but
for our purposes it all comes down to
one player's political opinion
conflicting business interests and
Blizzard decision to swing the ban hamma
I think this is something of a watershed
moment for eSports as far as I know it's
the first time a player has publicly
stated such a distinctly political
opinion and been slapped down for it by
a publisher whether you agree with him
or not
this kind of censorship could become
more common in the future and that's a
really difficult pill to swallow thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]